chaoui
[Applaudissements]
oh
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrêt
c'est tout récemment le retour au
travail de l'agronome qui a été aussi
lanceurs d'alertés louis robert qui est
devenu finalement la figure de proue le
du dossier des lanceurs d'alerté de tout
ce qui touche leur protection au québec
avec toute la saga politique que ça
engendrés par la suite alors oui il est
de retour au travail depuis quoi un
petit peu plus d'une semaine maintenant
mais surtout il est sur notre plateau ce
soir pour parler un petit retour sur
tout ça bonsoir monsieur robert content
de vous avoir avec nous sur les plateaux
comment il compte en effet comment vous
vivez si vous avez vu les images c'était
vrai y'a pas longtemps avec le comité
d'accueil la chanson laquelle émotions
ça vous plonge beaucoup de joie beaucoup
de bonheur puis une partie des gens qui
m'ont qui m'ont accompagné durant toute
cette histoire là étaient présents mardi
passé sa mort ça m'a rappelé ce soit
tout le soutient plus que j'ai eue
c'était fantastique tout ça mais de peu
partout puis je dois en profiter
justement pour remercier les gens qui
m'ont qui m'ont appuyé au premier chef
les groupes de pop star de la montérégie
comme lupescu ville le club action semis
direct et d'être l'action billon qui ont
été dès les premières heures à mes côtés
mais mon syndical cgt pas tout seul la
famille évidemment ma conjointe les
enfants et mes amis proches et qui était
lui aussi ça fait une différence qu'on
soit beaucoup beaucoup et des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui ont signé
la pétition aussi et donc c'était non
j'ai eu beaucoup de soutien
quoique au début c'était plus difficile
passée on it com puis gelé dans ces
situations là non plus on se demande un
peu ce qui arrive de plancher tombe sous
nos pieds donc c'était au début c'était
pas évident il ya eu en plus cette
sortie du ministre à l'époque qui en
rajoute et un finalement en disant qu'il
va peut-être autre chose comment vous
l'avez vécu sur cette sortie j'avais de
la misère à comprendre c'est sûr
oui ce sera juste un peu
d'incompréhension de ma part mais disons
que c'est du passé je reconnais je suis
très reconnaissant envers le
gouvernement d'avoir changé l'audition
d'envoi de cette excuse y est vous avez
vécu des excuses du premier ministre
c'est pas banal quand même nom en effet
si c'est extrêmement réjouissant quand
quand c'est arrivé et a été suivie par
une démarche qui a mené à mr et
l'intégration donc ça je pense que ça a
plus de courage pour faire ça de leur
art et le je suis très content de la
tournure des événements tournent en ce
sens maintenant que vous êtes de retour
au travail ça se passe j'allais dire à
peu près comme vous j'avais prévu mais
je dirais encore mieux même je pense que
je retrouve quelque chose que j'aime
donne les raisons pourquoi vous êtes
intégré entre autres c'est avec eux qui
me passionne depuis que et donc je
voulais
voulait poursuivre ce travail là et
depuis on termine la deuxième semaine
puis j'ai déjà impliqué dans des
dossiers qui m'intéresse beaucoup
votre parole vous avez pris une grande
vous avez pris un grand risque avec la
parole en étendant third alerte
il ya eu des hauts et des bas la dernier
des moments vous avez pris la parole des
moments où vous avez cessé de parler il
y avait ce moment délicat de nita ya des
joutes le quitte en train de jouer avec
votre syndic oeil un processus
administratif pour revenir au travail
aujourd'hui
est ce que vous l'avez pleinement votre
liberté de parole même si vous êtes
revenu au travail c'est à dire que les
circonstances entourant la fuite dans
les médias la fuite dans les médias
c'est de circonstance écriture
exceptionnelle en 30 ans de carrière ça
me paraît jusqu'à ce jour n'ont été la
seule fois que je dirais si le prêt
exceptionnel et je dois 0,6 en passant
que moi je comprends très bien qui en
est un représentant de tous j'en ai
marre du ministère de l'agriculture
je dois mes propos représentent le
ministère de l'agriculture a tout et les
interventions publiques que je fais donc
il ya des balises que j'accepte
facilement sans problème
donc je pense que aussi une prise de
conscience un peu qui va dans un beau
dans le bon sens dans le sens qu' on ne
roule public et louis plus important que
ce qu'on a connu ces dernières années de
ce côté là un jury j'entrevois les
prochaines années de façon très positive
oui je m'attaque à ventouse pour louis
rabat mais je pense que je pensais des
enjeux par la force des choses on va
devoir
je pense à appliquer de façon plus
active dans des enjeux comme celui j'ai
soulevé ou concerne les pc on va en
parler déprécie cdh après la pause on va
se garder toute une partie où on va
parler des enjeux d'actualité mais là
puisque vraiment vous avez été connus et
vous avez vécu les les conséquences des
trains lanceur dallaire avez vous
l'impression puisque tu veux mais cannes
et c'est une enquête dans la protectrice
du citoyen qui est arrivé avec avec un
rapport avec des recommandations avec
des façons de faire avez vous
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
la suite de tous les lanceurs dallaire
sont mieux protégés je suis je me réfère
au rapport de la protectrice du poignet
qui vont exactement dans ce sens la
savoie que plus rigoureux dans
l'application de la loi qui est adoptée
en 2009 2016 est appliquée en 2004 et de
2007 donc des plus vigilants en
application de cette fois là c'est sûr
que ça va faire une différence et je
pense que c'est un aspect qui est assez
clair dans mon histoire c'est qu'elle
sait plus ballon tessa déclaré par plier
les autorités
on devrait aller vers ça donc je
comprends je pense être confiant lui
confiant la discussion avec la grenoble
lanceurs d'alertés retour au travail
maintenant pour louis robert monsieur
robert il ya une commission
parlementaire qui va commencer bientôt
sur les pesticides
en fait ça ça fait partie de la prise de
conscience que vous avez permis
finalement en étant lanceur d' alerte
les politiciens s'en sont mêlés vous
vouliez y aller vous à cette commission
oui je vais même plus très mon intérêt
d'aller déposer j'ai déposé un mémoire
est ce que vous savez si vous allez y et
non le sait pas encore qui doit décider
j'imagine que c'est les membres la
commission ou un comité un sous-comité
de l'extrême de savoir ce que vous
voulez lancer
cependant si on faisait un résumé c'est
un peu que je pense que les la
problématique des pesticides découle des
divisions de notre problème à s'assurer
de 2/3 des recherches je t'en fais
technologiques et des services-conseils
libre de toute ingérence d'intérêts
corporatistes ou commerciaux ça c'est un
des facteurs est aussi un autre facteur
qui touchent que seule la réception du
message par les agriculteurs les
producteurs
je pense qu'on devrait les producteurs
je peux me permettre un peu paniqué
critique une observation dix ans et que
les poses cas d'après reconnaître un peu
plus le bien fondé
transfert technologique qui vient de la
recherche publique et qui directement
dans leurs intérêts et ceux qui l'
intérêt du public évidemment
donc il ya deux comme deux facettes où
je verrai des priorités à mettre les
ressources en priorité de ce côté là je
pense que même si c'est par là qu'on
devrait régler ou encore améliorer la
situation des priorités pratique pardon
améliorer les pratiques et diminuer
l'usagé des pesticides gymnastique pas
recueilli une problématique est la
solution passe d'abord par une étape de
diagnostic c'est pas pour faire un
procès de qui que ce soit l'homme a
essayé il faut regarder qu'est-ce qui
n'a pas fonctionné pour l'améliorer et
le risque que je vois surtout pour des
gens qui sont pas spécialistes de la
question c'est de vouloir utiliser des
outils des correctifs majeurs pour une
problématique dont les causes sont assez
ciblées selon moi tout cas mon avis on
devrait se concentrer en priorité sur
certains aspects et non pas créer une
nouvelle structure de surveillance par
exemple des trucs comme ça je trouve que
ça irait dans la mauvaise direction
j'aimerais qu'on parle du rôle des
agronomes et quelque chose qui était
frappant qui est sorti dans l'actualité
dans les derniers mois c'est-à-dire ce
groupe là il ya une poignée d'agronomes
qui sont responsables de 50 % des
prescriptions de certains types de
pesticides et on sait demander jusqu'à
quel point les agronomes sont conscients
une crise on joue des pesticides et et
nous protège nos populations et
consommateurs sks qu'une prise de
conscience à faire ce côté des agronomes
je pense que oui le débat se débat
quasiment permanent depuis mois que je
suis à grand dam ça revient
régulièrement au début des années 2000
la question touche est exactement la
même question touché la question des
faits l'enjeu de la fertilisation des
plantes fertilisation à l'époque où le
règlement du seul environnement est
arrivé pour imposer l'obligation d'avoir
une de posséder un plan de fertilisation
payer le débord eu lieu à ce moment là
et c'est à présent le débat encore lieu
de ce côté en ce concerne les pesticides
donc c'est toujours pas réglé moi j'ai
pas poser une façon de régler et je
pense que si on n'avait pas le choix que
de passer par nous et éventuellement
vous avez entendu cette semaine lui paye
enfin je pense être la semaine dernière
lui payant qui dit on est prêt à prendre
un virage on est prêt à faire le deuil
mais on va avoir besoin d'un support du
gouvernement il va falloir qu'ils nous
appuient financièrement vous votre gars
là dessus est ce qu'ils sont dans le bon
chemin puisqu'il montre au gouvernement
mais je pense que de résumer la position
si bien compris ce qui a été publié
concernant leur mémoire est de déposer
ou qui a été déposé pardon je trouve que
c'est ça va ça va dans la bonne
direction générale mais sur ce point et
là j'ai une petite observation en phase
états et que je pense c'est la beauté de
la chose à faire donc le virage demande
pas nécessairement beaucoup plus de deux
fonds c'est entendu que le ps défend
cette position là puis je les comprends
mais dans le sont par exemple d'énigmes
continuer les risques est à peu près
nulles
puis c'est juste parce que
scientifiquement parlant peut pas parler
d' absolue de tandis que le risque zéro
mais il est proche très proche de zéro
les risques que le pôle star en cours si
ils retirent les unit continuelle de ces
semences
donc c'est un peu trop exagéré selon moi
donc plusieurs c'est un exemple mais
d'ailleurs ça me permet d'ajouter que
comme à grenoble au mapaq je suis un
acteur parmi d'autres où on essaie de
transmettre transférer des techniques
qui sans coût supplémentaire même
augmenté leurs prix aux entreprises et
en même temps à mes huit impacts
environnementaux
donc il ya des solutions rapidement dans
une grosse révolution dans absolument
tous ces changements qu'il soit demandé
quiconque est aussi le danger que je
suis à la commission c'est d'éviter de
réclame encore plus de recherches avant
d'avoir fait un inventaire de ce qu'on a
parce qu'on a beaucoup d'outils en
recherchant transfert technologique
peut-être qu'à manque un peu ce côté de
la recherche a certainement mais
commençons pour faire le parfait de
vente est d'appliquer que son nom a déjà
pris on ferait des progrès énormes selon
moi mais ce revers ce plaisir de parler
de votre spécialité avec vous on parle
d'agronomie avec un agronome bas encore
une fois bon retour au travail
et puis on va vous suivre si jamais vous
comparaissez effectivement de
commissions pour voir comment votre
message va être reçue merci pour notre
musée merci beaucoup